how's it going Rose - purify so last
episode I apparently made every wrong
decision I ever made
so it's time for me to get my [ __ ]
together and it's teii I want to give an
excuse for it but III say Yolo let's
play I don't [ __ ] know that was the
best excuse ever alright she's back
where is he he's gone what if he comes
back oh yeah we saw this what if you
don't take pictures next time how about
that maybe then we wouldn't be in this
trouble trouble trouble we need to find
the others we can't go outside
Clementine Sarah you were with Nick
right we gotta go find him immune was
here what what did she say someone came
to the cabin
what talk to him and you just open the
door for him calm down
Rebecca calm down oh [ __ ] tom you calm
down we don't know anything yet he was
coming in either way it was I told you
not to open the door for anyone that's
name did he say what his name was maybe
it wasn't him you know damn well who it
was his name was said his name was
George George that's what he said
look Clem just tell us what he looked
like what was he wearing
did he sound different as I said a voice
was gravely look how I don't know kind
of deep and Scratchy he talked about you
dad
you're not gonna hurt anyone are you of
course he won't Sara your dad's the
nicest man I know which is why he's not
gonna do anything crazy or not nice
right oh you know these are bad people
sweetie they will do or say anything to
hurt us
now what do you think it seemed like
he'd be coming back he saw a picture of
me a picture what were you doing taking
pictures Carlos what you need to calm
down now you're scaring your daughter I
took the picture it's my fault no I
asked her to it's my fault
Sara
so distracted by that duck he was a
scouting we got lucky he wasn't
expecting to find us Clementine must
have surprised him she hadn't been there
well he was too smart to stick around
but he'll be back with the rest we don't
have much time he's right
everyone pack up we're moving now Alvin
wait in the thousand or have to leave
now sweetie before he comes back with
more bad guys but it's gonna be okay
let's just go get your things why did
you leave his camp yeah why it was we
had to that's not an answer I don't know
what he told you but William Carver is a
dangerous man he's the leader of a camp
not far from here and he's very smart
we were lucky to escape look I'm sorry
to involve you but now that he's seen
you you'll be safer with us we have to
leave yeah I think I called the Carlos
smart as well so his name is gotta find
Nick on our way out of here you know
where he was right yeah
all right everybody grab his stuff let's
hit the road if we gotta go Michael why
wasn't Mike oh that's that's a fine
Eisley knee you said it was just up here
yeah just a little ways hey Clem sorry
if I gave you some [ __ ] back there I'm
just a little on edge I still don't like
what you did sneaking around on us and
taking advantage of my husband but I
know you were in a tough spot I'll try
to cut you some slack it's okay if it's
not you I'm yelling at lately it's Alvin
and then I'm in real trouble I can
handle it
I'm not a little kid the same way when I
was your age my dad was always giving me
[ __ ] and I always thought he didn't know
when damn pain I know you did your best
back there you know none of us would
make it on our own sometimes it's hard
knowing just how dependent I am on
everyone I'm not used to that I'm not
comfortable with that I'm supposed to be
a mom soon guess I need to work on my
patience Alvin and I still don't know
what to call her or him if that man gets
his wish
god help me any ideas I just don't care
god I'm bored oh wait is here that's why
there that's where we were
he's totally gonna be let's be honest
oh god you're so pretty so precious I
love what you did with your hair
Nick it's probably making outdoor with
one of those Amy's
hmm so they think he's dead he's
obviously not dead come on
that was with game that jar I don't
remember the song it's sorry Jesus
hey man you got any aspirin Nick you
[ __ ]
why don't they shake if he was bent
it's bad I know me and I do we gotta get
moving
okay Carver's gangs shut up can you make
it yeah yeah let's go hey Clem
I just wanted to say thanks for not
giving up on me
of course anytime I'm sorry about Pete
man I'm sorry about Pete yeah thanks no
I reminded him of him what happened back
there in that cellar he do something
stupid like you can tell me I'm just
looking out for it okay drunk I was
scared
god damn it Nick I'm worried about that
kid keep an eye on him for me would you
you sure you still want to come with us
honestly I don't know I know we got off
to a rough start and I can't make any
promises it won't get rougher but we all
know you know we may not be perfect but
we look out for each other yeah I am I'm
with you guys and we are glad to have
you not everyone is well they'll get
there I figure we got about four or five
days to reach those mountains now if
they're tracking us we should be able to
lose them up there five days it's gonna
be okay back they have to keep moving
now it's our only choice like how the
hell do they get food can you imagine
getting food for seven people every day
in the wilderness that sounds impossible
like and they'd be surviving for a while
now it's so like obviously all the
extras had to be I don't know I I don't
I would be dead directly in one day but
you bros probably forget that our thanks
to Mike locking decision-making is that
a guy watching oh it's him okay
[Music]
so we rounded the place
[Music]
see anything
she better see some hmm we've been
walking for it damn week you've got to
find some big house building on the
mountain what's it look like
it's big that sounds like a good place
to spend the night yeah oh it seems like
there's something chairlift must be that
ski resort I've never been skiing beckon
I would once it wasn't pretty
neither is your face oh sorry sorry
I don't know but passable I think so
good that seems like a crap house by the
bridge how big is it it's pretty small
it's we have to cross that bridge let's
go hold on now you can't I'll go
sprinting across that thing okay we get
spotted out there we're gonna be trapped
going around that map don't take too
long right but yeah we've got no idea
who's out there
okay I'm gonna sneak across make sure
it's clear before we bring the whole
group over you think splitting up the
camp was a good idea I never said it was
a good idea but it's better than risking
everyone at once what's your plan
Clement I can scoot across low and slow
make sure nobody's waiting for us on the
other side we'll have a tough time
covering you from back here well we'll
just turn back if it gets hairy
Clementine should stay here shoots
she's what she's just a yeah what am i
she's a valuable little girl I mean hell
if she can sew up her own arm she's fit
to cross a bridge I can do it I can do
and see yeah no problem
it's gonna be fine okay we'll signe you
guys in ten minutes just watch for a
light at the far side I can go - you
stay with the group mm I'm fine Luke I
don't like this yeah well when's the
last time you'd liked anything Carlos if
something happens I'll grab come on
I think we should maybe hang no
nevermind hey sorry about that I just
could really use your eyes and right now
I don't trust Nick - ties
shoes you're just still on edge after
the Carver thing it's been five days
why would Carver still be following us
what's the most important thing in this
world
what does everyone even the gangs they
know what do you think they're all after
our family it's a tough world out there
without people you can trust huh anyway
see you can ask Rebecca okay I'm not
gonna get in the middle of it we've all
made mistakes done things that we regret
seems like we're already in the middle
of it tell me about it how could they
not seen them before
hmm that guy was pretty can't shoot him
too much noise
there are only two I don't know yeah I
like your style
I'll take the big one you get shorty
wish we could use God I like this we
should be okay got it I'll take the
small one good let's do it oh we're a
little hammering she's so cute
they're all so damaged Oh must be some
shampoo or something ah yes good pull it
should come free I know I've done this
before remember in a shed Oh sassy clam
is the best clam yeah yeah good job work
kid
oh I don't like this man that wood is
gonna crack for someone main I just hope
climbing will be yeah okay
[Music]
now come on we're fine
oh say what I say oh [ __ ]
well so is he okay oh [ __ ] oh don't
[ __ ] swear I don't get what's out oh
come on this can't be good
really bad
[Music]
come on clam
oh [ __ ]
kick her by one massive mister - oh
there there
oh god that was like last to be a little
second Oh big slap
do you like deep throating match Oh
Betty Dez what a [ __ ] baby
you gonna be okay
I wouldn't do that
oh we're dead a bride that's like
anything's me you should've gotten
[ __ ] cover anytime bros f let's keep
going alright let's check out this cabin
knit cabin cabin e Kevin that's with the
weather you see him just play it cool
do you do the talking what why me I
don't want to get in a fight you really
think he chewed a little girl just don't
make any sex and don't piss him off and
I'm sure it's me on anything is he with
Carver it was hard to see I don't think
so
oh gosh decision making time okay just
pull your [ __ ] together pills who are
you
who's asking I am want to help me out
here what do you want
what are you in so are you coming and I
thought I'd meet you halfway
I don't like thank go away
huh you don't look like [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] no offense or anything but you
know how it is out here
you run into a lot of [ __ ] we're
just people we're just people fair
enough you folks headed north like
everyone else everyone else I see at
least one group a day moved through here
you all look the same it's like a great
migration of the dazed and confused have
you seen someone named Krista Krista
maybe really no I mean a lot of people
come through here I don't know I gotta
say you two look like [ __ ]
if you need food I've got some canned
stuff in that station back there well
that's uh awful nice EU what's the catch
no catch
yeah I've got plenty well alright then
thank you hey no problem nice running
into friendly faces out here like I said
I've got food and supplies back in the
station and if you want what what what
watch watch watch watch watch what she
doing oh no what do i do what are you
doing what is wrong with you
where is it oh I told you not to shoot
what who was that guy why didn't you
wait why did you shoot he pointed a gun
at me damn it Nick I told you not to
shoot how was I supposed to hear you you
gave me a clear shot that shot rang out
for miles we got to get off this bridge
let's go god damn it pull your [ __ ]
shake he's worse than me I don't know
look like he had a gun on you that
[ __ ] drew on me he was about to shoot
Oh was he
tanja man he drew first that's not what
it looked like to me everybody calm down
what did you see Klem was that guy gonna
shoot [ __ ] you Luke you've been on my
case the whole week and why do you think
that is Nick because you're an [ __ ]
thing out of this I'm saying
either way you could have hit one of us
yeah but I didn't look I know Pete was
close to you Nick
but you can't [ __ ] talk about him you
think it was with Carver I don't know I
know I don't think so but he fell over
he fell off the damn bridge we have to
keep moving
I can't see a minute fine look he
doesn't need a [ __ ] talk that guy
needs a [ __ ] talk that guy that guy
is an idiot hey Clem you got anything to
eat Beck's dying here Alvin I told you
I'm fine sorry I wish we still had those
juicy boxes yeah me too that well the
guy said he had food in the station mind
taking it out maybe we could spend the
night here a little small for us though
you could use a little Batman iron he
may have been lying about the food it's
worth check it out either way yeah
okay so I hope he was lying because I
feel [ __ ] bad okay
you can't I'm Clem okay I'm clam I'm
playing [ __ ] I'm clam
I'm clam [ __ ] I'm clam [ __ ]
don't don't don't talk to me don't sass
me
don't fart on me I fought on you enjoyed
watching what's in the [ __ ] name oh
[ __ ] just aa game is awesome they're
like who's doing watching buzz see
tomorrow when you one of us